[Música]
o no
sí
[Música]
bergeron y que en cada alcabala tienen
que dejar un mercado y si hay por lo
menos hay puestos y si se le deja
mercancía que es barata por ejemplo como
es repollo lechuga muchas veces que
estas baratas ahí también dice no
nosotros no somos muy ricos y tienen que
bajarle tomate papa lo más caro que
llevan
[Música]
e
i
[Música]
1 puesto que pasar por la mano el
matraqueo pero si uno la busca la manera
más suave con más de tranquilidad porque
entre más fuerte devuelve a uno peor
pues para ello lo único que tiene en el
poder son ellos
[Música]
y
eso se llama operación recogió aplican
para será para para sacarle a uno en el
dinero pero uno al final también se
aguanta porque si empiezan a dejar una
marca vale nada siguiente se acostumbran
y después no llegamos aquí a cara que
las ganancias se le ha dejado todo ello
ni camino
[Música]